- I've never ate so much
kimchi in my life in one day.
- But you don't feel
guilty 'cause it's healthy.
(lounge jazz music)
- Today we are here to
try customizable kimchi
from Kind People Kimchi.
- I do love kimchi, I've tried it
before with Korean barbecue.
- Kimchi is traditional
Korean pickled cabbage,
to say it easy,
it has a lot of health
benefits, probiotic, uh, too.
(strumming electric guitar)
- [Claire] Orange,
pineapple, lobster, gold,
mango, oyster, kiwi, apple, caviar.
- [Grace] Yeah.
- Most importantly, yes.
(laughs)
- I like this look, look at that.
- [Themo] Looks exclusive.
- Let's see.
One, two, three.
(laughter)
- The smiling face, there it is.
- Wait, we need to put our
pinky up 'cause this is classy.
- [Grace] Hey, bougie.
- I feel like I'm taking a bite out of,
like, I don't know, the most
clearest water or something.
- Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah,
it's very refreshing.
- Yeah, that's more
vinegary than I thought.
- Yeah?
- I really like it.
- Jongman, how spicy is that?
- It's a little bit
spicy, wanna try this one?
- I'll have some.
- It actually is the first
time he's trying something.
- A lil' spice?
Put a lil' spice in your life.
- Wow.
- Spicy.
- Yeah, it is spicy.
- Really?
- Yeah, dude, you call
that, like, lil' spicy?
- Yeah, little spicy.
(exhales)
- What's the difference
from the red and then.
- It looks spicy.
- It's seasoned the same way,
but then this one has red pepper in it.
- Oh, how about this?
Gold.
- Gold?
Gold kimchi?
- Yeah, look at that.
- I'll try that one.
- Wanna try gold?
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- [Themo] How about that?
(laughs)
- Oh, he likes it.
- It is sweet, wow, I like that.
- Kinda sweet.
- Yeah.
- See, see, it doesn't necessarily
have to be spicy all the time.
- I know.
- Know what I mean?
- You trying the gold one?
- Mhm.
- Do you taste the gold?
- It tastes like seafood to me.
Am I just weird?
- Maybe.
- Mango.
- Mango is best?
Lemme try mango.
- Yeah, mango is good, wow.
- [Jay] Wow, mango taste.
- Yo, the mango is amazing.
- That's really good.
- I really like the pineapple one.
- My favorite is pineapple
right now, definitely.
- This is so good.
- My favorite's apple right now.
So for this, you do chew it.
Yeah, see, that I've only
had in the, like, the shot.
- Oyster shot.
- Yeah, like. (slurps)
- You don't like the seafood, right?
- I don't.
- I'm gonna go for it, guys.
(laughter)
- Are you scared?
- Yeah, I'm scared.
(humming)
- Chug that!
(laughter)
- What do you think?
- Nah!
- Oh no!
- Oh, I'm sorry.
Eat some of the gold one.
- I feel like I just
licked a sea creature.
- Oh no!
- I gotta say, look-wise, it's the gold.
But overall, the mango was amazing.
It was really, really good.
- You prefer it on the sweet, right?
- Yeah, definitely.
- I would say the kiwi.
I like the kiwi in kimchi is great.
- For me, you can put gold anywhere,
oh, you know, I'm gonna love it.
(laughter)
I just love it, you know?
Actually, I've never
had gold entire my life.
- I like everything
that I've tried so far,
even the spicy one.
- I like caviar and pineapple,
so I think I'll maybe try to mix them up.
- I feel like it changes
every time I go back.
- [Grace] Really?
(laughter)
- [Eliana] Yeah.
Well, I definitely know
that the oyster is not.
- No, no.
- No, no, no.
- Not my cup of tea,
everything else, for sure.
It's a delicacy that could be placed
on really anything, I feel.
(cheerful whistling music)
(swoosh)
(creak)